it's giving Tuesday tomorrow everyone
which is one reason why we are very
happy to have our first guest here today
you may know him best as an awardwinning
actor and musician but he's also got a
podcast where he talks with people about
giving back and changing the world for
the better it's called six degrees with
Kevin Bacon you can listen wherever you
get your podcast everybody give it up
for Kevin
Bacon
[Music]
oh my gosh you you're in a band you get
that do you just get up on stage
sometimes and go
huh yeah I do often times and I have to
say I love this outfit oh thank you so
good
than can I say that yeah it reminds me
of the
1968 Elvis Comeback Special yes ever
seen that no but anytime I remind
someone of the king I'm totally cool let
me tell you you w watch the 1968 Elvis
comeback special I he's basically he's
basically coping your style he yeah Back
to the Future there we go yeah it's like
but you I just moved here so you first
moved here a while back but what was it
like when you first 1976 I moved here uh
did you love it I loved it yeah I grew
up in Philly and um not far yeah it's
not far it's not far I've been here a
few few times because my sister lived
here my sister lived on um on West End
Avenue so she was very nice to let me
sleep on her couch for probably I don't
know four months until I got my feet
that's nice on the ground yeah yeah cuz
it's not a cheap City no no although I
can tell you that in
1976 uh my budget for my apartment was
$150 a month so you lived in a closet
right well of someone else's of someone
else's closet right
well that what what happened was it was
I IID figured that it was 100 I don't
know where I got the math on that but
that's what that's how I that's what I
had decided yeah and um so I went into
this I saw an ad in the back of the
Village Voice and it said uh artists
actors musicians residence and I thought
well that's that sounds good it was
basically a flop house really I
mean I don't I guess there were some
some artists there but not a lot like do
you mind living with rats exactly yeah
exactly but I walked into the into the
rental office and the guy said no we
don't have any single room Apartments uh
but we do have a two room apartment so
basically it was a kitchen and another
room and uh I said he said that's three
and a quarter a month and I said I can't
afford that and I don't have a roommate
and he said what about this guy I'm
sitting on the couch and I I looked of
this guy and he goes you want to live
together and I was like yeah okay yeah
okay we'll live together yeah and we
lived together for 4 4 years oh my gosh
yeah in fact I just had uh lunch with
him the other day and um uh he was a he
was a classical
pianist uh really were you both
musicians yeah that's cool yeah he he
was he's great great um played beautiful
I mean I you know in the middle of the
afternoon he worked nights at the Copa
gabana and in the middle of the after
this is a TV show this is like what yeah
yeah I I i' he'd come home and he'd be
playing you know showan or whatever and
it was it was it was really cool that's
incred I actually moved out to LA with
some random person I did not know really
yeah she just needed a roommate I was
like I'll do it I was like and I moved
from Texas to LA with a stranger wow how
long did that last not long we moved
into a place and it burned down um so
yeah then I slipped in my car for a few
days and then tried out for a show
called American Idol so it all worked
out that work
out life yeah I feel like everyone in
this IND you have some crazy thing where
you've either lived in your car or on a
mattress in someone's house or yeah it's
like yeah you really got to want your
dream you do you got to have the hung
the universe makes you really want it um
but you played with Billy Joel at
Madison Square Garden that is incredible
I did yeah it was amazing I would like
to do that I were you nervous oh my God
were you kidding me of course of course
I was nervous yeah I wouldn't have been
nervous about the audience I would have
been nervous about him well yeah I mean
listen I you know know it's one of those
moments where you look at the they they
sent me the set list and I looked at the
set list and I was like oh wow every
single one of the songs on this set list
like a massive hit is like a massive hit
and it was just a weird thing because
yeah I'm a Billy Joel fan but i' never
met Billy we didn't know each other um
and he reached out uh to say did Kar and
I want to come to the show and I said
yeah of course and we were like wow
that's awesome Billy Joel was we can go
to we can go to the show at the Garden
and then like about a week later was
like do they want to come to the show
and also do a song I was like what it
was literally if I if I could do the it
was like it was like a you know and then
grab tequila grab tequila yeah you're
like wait what about this decision right
I had the tequila ready for after the
for after yes that was probably smart
that was a smart decision yeah so it was
really fun but you're not just actor Bo
you just got honored in Philly you got a
A my yeah on the fck of him that's so
cool that's amazing Leslie odm Jr was
just here like a week ago he got he got
that too yeah he's from pH as well yeah
yeah yeah that's prestigious yeah listen
I mean Philadelphia has an amazing music
tradition yeah um Pink's from Philly too
yeah pink there's a lot of good people
coming
out uh
congratulations John Oats I mean and
just the the sound of Philadelphia all
those you know Kenny Gamble Leon Huff
all all those great song writers and and
uh it was it was a it was really cool I
mean this is a street that you know is
only a few blocks from where I grew up
so wow that's that makes it more special
that's really cool
[Applause]
awesome all right y'all we are back with
Kevin so Kevin actually plays a few
instruments and just learned another so
let's see that this is called Pig BT
goes like
this
like first of all we didn't show the
beginning where you're kind of rubbing
up against her her hair that was also
nice the sound it was like a little
washbish do you play on pigs yeah he has
very very uh uh is very bristly yeah he
he sounds great that pig he does he
really does well speaking of pigs
something just happened in Kevin's home
state that had a lot of of people
worried um here are some headlines Kevin
Bacon the pig not the actor missing
after PA Barn Escape Kevin Bacon remains
on the run in Central PA it feels like
I'm on SNL right now um an escaped pet
pig named Kevin Bacon is becoming an
internet sensation uh I heard you
actually helped find Kevin Bacon well I
didn't help find Kevin Bacon with the
flashlight no I I I pointed out that he
was missing I know but you have a lot of
followers well I I don't know if if I
was helpful I'm I'm thrilled yeah it's a
great name for a pig as all it's amazing
it is I'm mad I never thought of it we
had a pig named her 80 but should have
named it Kevin Bacon um yeah but we we
have a family member of Kevin Bacon the
pig in our audience um Everybody meet
Chelsea what's up
Chelsea so you found the pig right we
found the pig we found the bacon did you
find out where Kevin Bacon was so was he
in a barn
dancing he did wander close to the barn
but there was no dancing okay
disappointment all right all right how
did how did the pig get home how did you
end up figuring it out so he was on the
lamb for about two and a half weeks and
you know we had shared on social media
about it because I didn't want the local
Hunters to find my pig and make a make a
mistake so um we put it online and then
Kevin Bacon human uh shared the story
about Kevin Bacon Pig and
honestly it how many times do you think
we'll say Kevin Bacon in this episode
amazing a million yeah um it was really
renewed hope when Kevin Bacon human
shared it it was getting a little rough
in the trenches and um you know the next
thing we knew somebody was suggesting
that I put out donuts for Kevin Bacon
Pig so I didn't have Donuts but I got
sticky buns and pet safe benad yeah so I
love that you said pet safe you're like
don't attack me people there it is yeah
I took a bite out of it first it's fine
um and took a
nap yes he wandered on in sleepily and
now he's home forever and safe a that's
sweet I love pet are our family yeah you
know what's
interesting is
that my wife often uses sticky buns and
and badril to to lure me in this is
a to get you to go to sleep I have so
many jok that aren't daytime right now
it's
[Music]
[Applause]
fun thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home